bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy andrés suárez jaramillo
sudan atraviesa días convulsos tras un
nuevo golpe de estado-militar que ha
puesto fin al gobierno de transición de
abdala andoc un capítulo violento más en
la política de un país cuya historia
está marcado por los conflictos armados
internos sudán nació como país
independiente en 1956 en medio de una
cruenta guerra civil entre el norte y el
sur el norte con una predominancia de
población árabe mientras el sur con una
mayoría cristiana repartida en grupos
étnicos de origen subsahariano este
desgarrador conflicto dejó más de medio
millón de muertos en 16 años les
estabilizó y empobreció por completo a
la nación que a pesar de haberse creado
como una democracia sufrió su primer
golpe de estado en
el poder militar es clave para entender
la política sudanesa tras el primer
golpe se inauguró un periodo de
gobiernos inestables culminó con otra
toma forzosa del poder estatal en
1969 por parte del coronel gafar nimeiri
con email y sudán vivió cierta
estabilidad aunque este militar suprimió
toda libertad política logró firmar la
paz con el sur en 1972 con los acuerdos
de addis abeba pero su acercamiento al
islam y la imposición de la ley islámica
en 1983 desató la segunda guerra civil
sudanesa esta guerra fue aún peor que la
anterior el conflicto y un período de
sequía desataron una serie de hambrunas
que afectaron a millones de personas
especialmente en el oeste del país este
desastre humanitario fue ocultado por el
gobierno del email algo que precipitó su
derrocamiento en
el final de nimeiri trajo más
inestabilidad y el surgimiento de un
nuevo nombre que a la postre se
convertiría en el hombre fuerte de sudán
por cerca de 30 años omar al bashir al
bachir llegó al poder en 1989 e instauró
un régimen personalista de partido único
que se acercó progresivamente hacia el
fundamentalismo islámico para finales de
la década de 1990 eeuu incluyó a sudán
en la lista de estados terroristas por
sus nexos con osama bin laden y al qaeda
washington acusó a jartúm de fabricar
armas químicas para este grupo e incluso
lanzó ataques específicos a fábricas
el fundamentalismo de al bashir propició
el inicio de otro conflicto en sudán por
una cuestión religiosa en 2003 el
ejército de liberación de sudán tomó las
armas contra el gobierno en darfur al
acusarlo de oprimir a la minoría no
árabe las matanzas en esta región se
prolongaron durante años algo que hizo
que la corte penal internacional de la
haya emitiera 2 de detención contra al
bachir bajo la acusación de genocidio y
limpieza étnica a pesar de los numerosos
intentos de acuerdo de alto el fuego y
la presión internacional los ataques
gubernamentales en la zona se sucedieron
durante años todos tuvimos que ir y
nuestras casas fueron quemadas nuestros
hijos fueron asesinados no se han
destruido luego nos recogieron y nos
trajeron aquí
el conflicto interno sudanés dio un
respiro a su población a partir de 2005
con la firma de los acuerdos de nairobi
que pusieron fin a la segunda guerra
civil sudanesa el norte y el sur del
país firmaron una paz tras 22 años de
guerra 19 millones de muertos y más de 4
millones de ciudadanos desplazados desde
el 2005 hasta el 2011 se revivió la
figura del gobierno autónomo de sudan
del sur dentro de un estado unificado
pero esa idea caducó pronto para los
separatistas de la región que decidieron
organizar un referendo de independencia
el 9 de julio de 2011 la votación dio un
rotundo sí a la independencia con el 98
83 por ciento de los votos una decisión
que fue aceptada por jartúm y que
precipitó la división de sudán en dos
estados sudán y sudán del sur
la creación de sudán del sur brindó más
crédito a la malograda reputación
internacional de al bachir pero la
independencia del sur supuso la pérdida
de una cuarta parte del territorio y de
la región con mayor cantidad de recursos
naturales algo que influyó en la
economía del país más recientemente en
la última década el descontento hacia el
bashir fue creciendo así como las
intenciones de derrocarlo del poder
desde diciembre de 2018 las marchas
aumentaron la población mostró su
hartazgo por tres décadas de férreo
control militar
violencia aislamiento y pobreza y miles
de sudaneses salieron a las calles hasta
que en abril de 2019 al bashir sufrió un
golpe por parte del ejército que lo
depuso del poder
permaneceremos aquí hasta que se cumplan
nuestras demandas la primera es dar
poder a los ciudadanos hacer que los
criminales rindan cuentas entregar a
bashir a la corte internacional y
llevarlo ante la justicia aquí en el
país
aquel episodio fue el final del hombre
fuerte de sudán y el inicio de un nuevo
período inestable en el que el poder
civil intentó ser parte activa de la
política de sudán el país vio progresos
internacionales al dejar de aparecer en
la lista de estados terroristas y el
procesamiento de al bachir ante la corte
penal internacional pero la profunda
crisis económica y la sombra permanente
de la casta militar nunca desaparecieron
haciendo que una vez más un golpe de
estado haya tomado por la fuerza el
control de la nación así concluimos los
textos y la edición son de álvaro
cordero a ustedes gracias por compartir
y comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]